welcome back to G few rules I'm Adam
Rapoport here with award-winning jeweler
designer Hilary his studio in the lower
Manhattan right so what kind of mid
Manhattan I mean everyone Midtown south
Midtown south felt like that without
thought to be honest when I heard the
word jewelry I'm always like careful
yeah I'm a guy kiss can I wear jewelry
a 100% 100% how do you take that first
step
I think the most important thing is like
anywhere you should feel like yourself
lotta guys in a wedding band a lot of
guys were a watch I got one right I got
jewelry on the next logical step might
be a bracelet like a cuff bracelet the
most guys used to having something on
the wrist so the notion of having one
more bracelet or something or a chain
next year watch makes sense
this is one that we do really love it
it's a brass railroad spike cuff you
just sort of slip it over your wrist
she's a slow to miss lips family exactly
I mean it's got a kind of industrial
feel it's got pounded shiny it's got a
hammered finish it doesn't have that
brand-new Jackie on her t-shirt feel you
want them that's a little worn in this
looks cool I have no idea what it's a
black and stainless steel with 14-karat
gold
it's got a rich soft finish to it almost
looks like leather from a little bit of
wreck it goes well with tattoos goes
well I think guys are used to wearing
rings if they're married
this one looks cool this is a what is it
it's not overly shiny I like that it's
stainless steel forged a line of 24
karat gold so it's got this real flashy
quality to it but it's inside and also
becomes your own like personal little
secret you're still boxer shorts of
jewelry you know it's expensive and nice
the whole world of
this is my personal necklace I don't
wearing this three years it has one of
the earliest prototypes about anchor
which I've been making for years as an
old family ring it has a religious
design from the grandmother on the
anchor is a kind of universal symbol
like everybody's got an association with
anchor but it's not religious who
doesn't want to be a sail
exactly all of those things I connect
with so I think what I'm wearing in it I
feel like me maybe it also means
something Japanese because it gets a
part of your personal style without
making a huge statement you know you
don't want the joy to wear you you want
to wear it yeah and I think if you do
that you start off with the wrist piece
or going to get a necklace and get a
ring and you know next thing you know
you look like Philip it Phil thank you
very much I'm at rapport thank you for
watching GQ rules and tune in tomorrow
for another essential style tip